the Lincoln Park carpool karaoke filmed
before chester bennington death plus
Beyonce's anthem freedom gets an assist
from some serious girl power hello
friends this is the daily Denny and
thanks for coming back to hang out with
us you know it's hard to believe that
it's already been nearly three months
since the death of Linkin Park frontman
Chester Bennington today the band's
episode of carpool karaoke the series
was released on Facebook it was filmed
just days before Chester was found dead
of an apparent suicide in the clip
Chester is in such good spirits riding
along with his bandmates and comedian
kim ji-young that it's actually almost
hard to watch he even teaches Ken how to
scream sing okay so the key to springing
screaming yeah
scream singing it's all screams to
scream singing it's unlike yelling where
you like yelling it's somebody you want
to like relax the voice use your
diaphragm so when you hit it like a like
a note like a regular note that you can
sing like yeah like that yeah yeah okay
see that was rich Mike screams so close
okay he's got it huh he's got it don't
think about it just feel it it's got to
come from within yes yes this is
probably the greatest day of my life
right it is my life you are the best the
episode was originally going to air on
Apple music and at the time of Chester's
death James Corden told ET they would
handle it with respect but added it
would be up to both Chester's family and
the band no it's it's a it's it's a
tragedy and we will be as sensitive to
that if they were to say we respectfully
ask that it wouldn't be aired we would
never ever dream of airing it if they
would if they were to say we would love
it to go out we 100% do that but but we
don't even consider it to be our
decision really it will only rest in the
hands of their family and all those
people involved while James got that
blessing in fact the episode opened with
a message saying with the blessing of
Chester's family and his bandmates
we share this episode and dedicate it to
the memory of Chester and on October
27th Linkin Park will be putting on a
tribute concert
the Hollywood Bowl in honor of the late
singer alright switching gears to
Beyonce who just dropped a new video for
freedom only it's a youthful twist to
her global girl power track the
reimagining features fierce young
females from around the globe
lip-synching to Beyonce's battle cry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm a keeper running
[Music]
those girls aren't getting a lovely hey
the video was released on International
Day of the girl they're hoping to raise
awareness for issues like domestic
violence human trafficking and lack of
education the video benefits Beyonce and
Salma Hayek's chime for change
initiative now it goes without saying
but B is coming up on two decades of
writing girl power anthems survivor will
always be the jam single ladies run the
world the list goes on and on and on but
who can forget the og the one that put
Destiny's Child on the map I'm talking
about independent women and it just so
happens that et was on the set with
Beyonce back in 2000 well actually I
wrote the track in the vocals I did the
arrangements for something else and
Columbia Records heard the track and
they were like alright that has to be
the theme song for Charlie's Angels
soundtrack so I was like wonderful
[Music]
and it's a great song it's all about
women and independence it's called
independent women as a matter of fact
we're just excited and we were very
blessed to have the opportunity to be
the group to sing the theme song
[Music]
I love baby bee she's so baby she's a
little how was that for a throwback
Thursday huh you know I'm also getting
DejaVu seen these comedy icons together
Adam Sandler Dustin Hoffman and their
co-stars stepped out Wednesday night for
a special screening of their new Netflix
movie the Meyerowitz stories et caught
up with Sandler and his on-screen dad
but we also needed to ask about Adams
recent dinner with Justin Bieber that'll
be nice to spend time with Devin oh I
didn't get a lot of time with him
growing up I'd love to hear what it was
like with this guy playing you're damn
good felt very really he ignored me like
a good father should did nice made me
feel like I don't exist and I like that
and I'm gonna turn the question on you
now so what was it like Kevin not only i
but also been playing your son's I mean
that's what I have a cool opportunity
well I think Ben was my son before and
Adam is my son in real life we held it
back from him until last week breaking
news irani tea oh my god we love that
already told me this years ago
[Music]
homeboy good to see you man I have to
ask you about going out to dinner with
Justin Bieber that was like everyone I
do marry I mean your your stock must
have gone up as a dad and that was a
good thing at home yes but he's a great
kid he's funny as hell and we went out
to dinner I had a nice time he's really
great great guy funny just and he can
sing pretty well did you know he sings
and dances I didn't know he wanted
advice from me for the movie industry
would I don't know who said that that's
some weird story that they made up it's
not at all that we just hung out we just
hung out he wanted to go to dinner with
me and David Spade and Dustin and Dustin
said no he ran away so it's just me and
David favourite Justin Bieber song I say
let's get Biebs and Sandler and a movie
together
Big Daddy - let's make it happen are you
guys thanks so much for watching if you
like what you see prove it
like and share this video and of course
subscribe to e t--'s youtube channel and
i will see you guys tomorrow I win what
because I win